das was olaf scholz gestern gemacht hat
diesen fragenkatalog der teilweise
inquisitorisch ist also vier seiten 24
fragen 48 unterpunkte und zwar wirklich
bis ins detail rein also da ist richtig
dran geschraubt wurde hat man sich
richtig richtig mühe gegeben und da will
man jetzt und zwar aussieht ist wie die
bundesländern außer ist wie die
parteizentrale und natürlich auch vom
vizekanzler und kanzlerkandidaten olaf
scholz jetzt genau von jens spahn wissen
wo hat wir gepennt warum haben wir diese
trödel impfung warum fehlt und zum zum
jahresanfang so wichtiger impfstoff
warum wird im ganzen land die hotline
116 117 beworben
warum rufen jetzt millionen rentner oder
senioren oder den tieren angehörige in
diesen hotlines an und landen im
nirgendwo keine terminvergabe
geschlossene eben fünf zentren wie kam
es zu diesem desaster
wann hat wer entschieden dass etwas
nicht gekauft oder das etwas spät
gekauft wird diese fragen die
erschüttern jetzt natürlich diese kurden
diese koalition aber die fragen müssen
ja gestellt werden und im normalen jahr
hätte man die nicht gestellt jetzt haben
wir war ja zum glück hat herr scholz
sage ich man gestern diese fragen dann
mal auf den tisch geknallt vielleicht
kriegen auch wir dann endlich mal
antworten auf diese ganzen drängenden
fragen und da ist natürlich einiges in
bewegung es rappelt hier mächtig im
karton
also wir haben einmal jens spahn und die
und die kanzlerin da knirscht und knackt
es hörbar und sichtbar auch das
berichten uns mehrere leute nicht nur
aus dieser runde sondern auch aus den
letzten zwei tagen also die die
kanzlerin und jens spahn ob das noch mal
gut geht fragezeichen hinter dann haben
wir stolz und sparen
der vizekanzler und einer der möchtegern
kanzlerkandidaten eigentlich aus der
offizier die uni wien sparen
die beiden kennen sich also briefe jetzt
um die ohren fragenkataloge da ist
richtig da ist richtig was drin also die
koalition momentan für uns ist es schön
da ist stimmung drinnen
wir haben etwas zu berichten und es
werden anfragen auch in der regierung
gestellt nicht nur von uns von und
journalisten
und da ist jetzt keine einheitliche
front mehr die da die dann besteht
sondern da ist wie richtig richtig ungut
drin die ministerpräsidenten die
landräte die bürgermeister die werden
dir alle vor ort konfrontiert mit dem
unverständnis der der menschen die den
ist präsentiert von große impfzentren
die jetzt in deutschland arbeit
arbeitsfähig sind seit dem 15 dezember
stehen die
dann sollen die ersten lieferungen
kommen und dann sehen wir kleine kartons
die in großen lkws sind das ist alles
was in den industrienationen deutschland
ankommt kleckerweise tröpfchen impfung
das sind alles stichworte und die
sprechen sich herum und die leute machen
jetzt die erfahrung dass sie wie ihre
angehörigen keine impftermine kriegen
und das hat richtig potenzial hier
hinten ist eine bunte dran
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren